smoke Rises into the sky above keev the
aftermath of Russian missile strikes on
the capital that have killed many people
firefighters battle to put out the fire
at this Warehouse the owner views the
damage this is completely a civilan
warehouse there is no military
infrastructure here over 100 people were
working here the total value of damage
is around 12 million
dollar three people were killed when the
Missile hit
the Ukrainian Air Force says that this
is one of the largest attacks on
civilian infrastructure since the early
days of the war and although authorities
say that they've managed to stop the
majority of those strikes the sheer
scale and number of strikes taking place
means that the air defenses can't stop
everything and the ones that make it
through have deadly
consequences in zapara Rescuers retrieve
the body of a teacher after her house
was
hit I was inside my house when an
explosion rang thank God our house
wasn't hit by it but here it got head
strong in the port city of adessa a
residential Tower was
struck I woke up the children and we
started to get dressed we went down to
the parking on our feet broken glass
bricks and doors were scattered around
people ran with children bags and
pets in the northern city of KV Rescuers
work to pull out the trapped under the
rubble a maternity hospital and shopping
center were hit in the Central City of
Deno this attack comes days after
Ukraine claimed it destroyed a Russian
warship in
Crimea Russia's reply is of one of
overwhelming Force using drones missiles
and bombers and a reminder it can hit
any part of Ukraine Assad bag Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer